okay if your legs up lights yes it just
goes down it goes down there quickly
this has gotta work it's gonna work it's
definitely gonna work how's it going bro
today we're checking out extreme sisters
Anna Lucy TLC baby this is a weird one
we're like the luckiest twins in the
world like we're sure a man that totally
loves us for Who We Are
thank you
I know I understand why but do you have
to you have to talk like that I want him
to mess it up a man that loves us for
who we is [ __ ]
Ben is our hero he's our Prince Charming
he really is
so they share the same something husband
oh
okay
oh my God oh my God see I can do it too
third twin confirmed
oh he gives one to the other first
that's interesting wow well that could
symbolize the three of us
I would have expected him to put him on
at the same time right oh my God oh my
God we love them
oh my God I want to show you that I'm
committed to you
you mean the world to me and I want to
show you that I'm committed to you as
well
I want to spend the rest of my life with
you
why is it so funny with use and I love
yous he loves you's
yeah
oh my God oh God it's hilarious and
super annoying at the same time sorry
this video is sponsored by
yes
[Music]
you get three guesses wrong it's nordvpn
as we already established nordvpn
greatest VPN but not just nordvpn
nordvpn is more than VPN
they should use that we all know you can
use a VPN to connect to different
country so you can watch different
streaming shows online but they also
have private DNS which is essential for
your online security your internet
service provider keeps a public record
of all everything
even for years they're legally required
to do it nor VPN Shields all online
activities look how much better it is
they're always adding new cool features
like dark web monitor instead of having
to go all out of the way to check if
your email has been compromised nordvpn
does supporting it's like getting a
gentle massage oh I don't have to worry
about one of a million things anymore
thank you nordvpn it also comes built in
with driver protection which blocks
cyber threats in real time there's no
real good reason why you shouldn't have
it use my link okay I don't want to use
the link nordvpn.com PewDiePie is a link
click link click the goddamn link it's
an amazing service or a cheap monthly
subscription check it out thank you note
for sponsoring this video let's keep
watching I just love these Rings like
this symbolizes the three of us
it is so sentimental
I'm glad they don't do like at the same
time or something like that that'd be
weird okay I'm glad I'm not the only one
who feel creeped out I think we can get
married in Malaysia Indonesia other
parts of America
that was weird Malaysia Indonesia you
know what it doesn't matter who cares
okay they can get married we know those
places to get married for the three of
us and we'll make it happen we won't
stop until the three of us can get get
married together we've already Googled
it so
they Google it it's gonna happen sorry
that caught me off guard
Here's to Us Girls make sure they're the
same oh right the drink has to be the
same amount yeah they probably eat the
same amount don't they it makes sense no
it doesn't why am I just why am I trying
all right so if this wasn't bizarre
enough already it's about to get weirder
because they're trying to get pregnant
at the same time I think we're getting
close I'm like so freaking nervous
staying with me today we've come it'd be
fun if the other one was just like oh
not me I'm not nervous at all
oh sorry yeah I'm nervous uh right can
you tell me how can I help you
um we're thinking we want to start a
family soon soon
um we want to know our options how old
are both of you
are we 35 35 70.
there's so many together good job Thirty
fine I think these leaders are gonna get
some bad news to be honest amazing
and you have partners
we share our partner
we have one boyfriend that we share
together his name is Ben okay and we see
us having a child with him or both of us
not just one child two babies so okay
she needs to be pregnant okay no I think
you got that what the [ __ ] and I need to
be here at exactly the same time
in my life I haven't seen anyone sharing
the same partner and wanted to get
pregnant at the same time so yeah I was
a bit shocked to listen to what they how
are they gonna you know what I don't
wanna know that people see me today for
why are they subtitling him I can
totally understand what he's saying to
what date we're aiming for and what they
came to see me today for he has a light
accent get out of here like Japanese
people subtitling me speaking Japanese
and Katakana Khan I get the [ __ ] out of
here can I ask does he like need it with
me and then 10 minutes after like
straight away with Anna is that possible
yeah
why are you asking him now you didn't
ask your husband hey how else would you
do it
who gets priority I don't you know what
it's so weird if we guys can watch it
right oh my God what did the turkey
baster what
what did she say
no
they did not just
no stop you are you are not no oh my God
perfectly in her and then me is that
possible uh I suppose yes it may work
that was a good question
no no that was mine no no
that was a pretty good
the worst question I've ever heard you
want it to happen at the same time 15 is
about one in six so two at the same time
so one in 36 chance or one and thirty
six and get pregnant naturally at the
same time in the same month yeah yeah I
mean you're 35.
so it's quite low essentially what do
you mean yeah
I'm not We're Not Gonna accept that he's
not making those rules what do you mean
you're not gonna make sense
he's just telling him what it is how it
is well that's not good enough We're Not
Gonna accept that the statistics were
different might be a surprise to be
honest everything he said how do you not
know these I didn't realize how long it
was it wasn't that good like did it piss
you up really
I guess they didn't Google then
I'm weirdly into this this is hilarious
all right let's keep going so every
morning we'll be taking our temperature
checks and I've been writing them down
in the dining keeping check of it
because we learned from the internet
when the temperature goes up they must
have Googled it and they may they might
have banged it to be honest
is it ever going to go off
is it gonna go off at the same time
[Music]
I'm gonna wait for you mate
[Music]
36.8 exactly they're three degrees up
I'll be lighting I'll be lighting 36.8
that's a regular temperature right can
you guys explain this to me because uh
growing up I was told you should add 0.5
because normal body temperature is 37.2
right but the thermometer doesn't tell
exactly your body temperature so you're
if you're normal it should be 36.8 and
you just add the 0.5
indifference is that correct I actually
want to know but that means they're just
normal we're exactly the same
we're three degrees up we've increased
three degrees up oh my God
it's a terrifying sense
knowing the context of it
cameraman has to lean you think they
just wait outside okay
after sex you've got to put your legs up
on the wall for like half an hour so
we've been doing that like that's
because the Spanish
yeah if your legs are up famous to
Googled it they caught me on that one it
just goes down it goes down there
quickly this has gotta work
it's definitely gonna work pineapple for
you girls thank you
for how long are you gonna do this for
another half an hour we're gonna really
improve our chances of being pregnant
it's definitely a lot of pressure for
one guy it's a matter of multitasking I
guess yeah yeah tap tap your head and
rub your belly two things at once yeah
no wait what what happened in there I I
actually don't tell me what the [ __ ]
yeah well let's have some pineapple
which one's the same size
well do you reckon these are the same
yeah
thank you cheers cheers
all right
the question we've all been asking did
it work did they get pregnant at the
same time are you nervous yeah we are
all right so we've got to wait a couple
of minutes
all right
so a single line not pregnant
and a cross-line pregnant
waiting for the test results of
pregnancy test there was a lot of
anxiety like a lot I'm having a heart
attack because I'm thinking Anna could
be pregnant I'm not we prefer both of us
not be pregnant then one of us be
pregnant definitely okay all right that
line look there's a line I mean he did
explain it God damn it
damn it does that mean not pregnant
we're not pregnant
[Music]
I think they meant to say they're not
pregnant I don't know
no
we haven't let you down
no you're not gonna let me down
I'll just keep his facial expression
hasn't changed the entire time I've seen
him so I don't think
can he be disappointed I don't know
people keep trying
it's weird I was really rooting for them
for a while I don't know
this is why we need to have a qualifying
psychological exam to be a parent all
right my life isn't that bad things
yeah
I've never really need for you hey come
on don't be mean but this is a year ago
looking up I don't think they had any
luck guys so it's gonna be tough their
social media is something else I don't
I don't know exactly what I'm looking at
here but I am terrified all right no no
luck this time but I hope you guys
enjoyed watching if you did Smash like
subscribe